all right so there is trouble brewing  right now in the boba tea industry the  popular drink typically has those chewy  tapioca pearls in it  but that particular ingredient could be  in trouble for the next few weeks  this all started when the pandemic  caused congestion and shortages in the  supply chain  99 of the world's boa pearls come from  taiwan  and now there's a big backlog i mean  that'd be interesting to see how it  would actually impact our business  but we do have like a lot of  alternatives to boba no there are some  days where like  we do run out of boba like we stop  cooking it for the day or something  and some people do leave interesting so  for now shop owners are stocking up and  offering some alternatives until their  limited supply is replenished and i love  those straws  alright we'll be right back